[Music]
[Applause]
my name is education come I am 74 years 74
and I live in Italy
[Music]
for me work is still a source of
satisfaction and therefore leaving it too bad I
am a partner of  a company that produces
machines and plants for the treatment
of cereals
the plant is germany but the
production in germany italy that
the european community has set up in spain
is a company that operates in several
european countries a great leap in the
operational management of the company
before 2000  there was
exchange rate fluctuation there were customs controls
and a different classification
of products but she likes it is a synthesis
of safety and quality it is said that the
product is certified we point with a
sentence the definition of the product is finished I
work in Europe for
transport and  monday friday and monday in
italy i leave on tuesday morning and go either
to spain for a week or to germany
the other of conte stimulates the fact of
having  physically eliminated the borders it
was an incredible thing it seems
ridiculous today to think of going
back
the flight by plane you sleep to recover
the hours of sleep you lost during
the network
on the train you work as if it were in the office
but there are decisions that must be taken
collectively that  require
system meetings or then the original you want to
work with people from different countries
presents difficulties on the one hand and
great possibilities on the other
[Music]
for me Europe was not an option it
was a necessity
[Music]